We have a voice. Speaking of double standards,
we have a voicemail number, which you can call
any time. It's two one nine two. David P.
yesterday we talked about the Republican
double standard between the Trump sexual assault
allegations and the Andrew Cuomo sexual assault
allegations. This caller rightly points out
it goes well beyond just that as an example.
Hey, David, you raised a good point
recently of the double standard regarding
improper sexual allegations against men
in government and how, you know, Trump
actually got off very easily. But why is Cuomo
being lambasted so severely? And my question is
also about Supreme Court justices. Right. Clarence
Thomas, who he had very serious allegations lodged
against him by a subordinate employee, continues
to be on the bench for many years. And then also
I'm trying to remember the name of the one that
Trump appointed by Brett Kavanaugh. I think his
name is Brant. And I don't remember at the
moment. But that was also a very, you know,
many very, very serious allegations
of sexual impropriety against him.
But yet he continues on the Supreme Court highest
court in the nation, our court of justice.
Absolutely the double standard. I mean, listen,
we can talk about the double standard with Bill
Clinton. We can talk about the double standard
with, you know, Anthony Weiner, who was widely
denounced and abandoned by Democrats. You could
talk about the Al Franken situation. Certainly
the Clarence Thomas situation is a good one. It is
endless, endless, endless hypocrisy. And I'm glad
to have the the additional examples. We have a
great bonus show for you today. We will talk about
Milo Yiannopoulos saying that he's
been converted out of homosexuality.
We will talk about Idaho ending Powerball because
they fear foreign participation. And we will talk
about Arkansas passing a near total abortion
ban and what this could mean for Roe v. Wade.
All of those stories and more on the bonus show
get the bonus show every day, not weekends,
every weekday by becoming a member at
Join Pakman dot com. I'll see you then.